here's how this video is going to work
the next part of this video is a short
video essay entirely written by an
algorithm that algorithm was trained by
looking through dozens of scripts from
top YouTube creators and instructed to
write something similar when given a
writing prompt whatever the algorithm
wrote I then performed and animated
after the video essay I will then show
you how I did this and why
machine learning is here to stay on
YouTube keep an ear out and see if you
can hear the influence of some of your
favorites educational channels an SSL
favorite cloud aspect ratio of the story
continues in bowing up feeling Netflix
materials put new testing that the proto
version Union takes their screens with
the owned of the math and the suburbs is
beginning to be budging warm during the
time the protagonist is in the script
and if you do some of them and then set
me that you can do to make sure that
you're going to be rid of this to fill
in the algorithms and if you have a lot
of artificial core writing Jane's
incredibly important to tech the channel
on the music plan check it out we can
also say that you can do something else
don't worry I'll need to do is if you
want to learn the fundamentals to music
keys because the most important feeling
serves by the gap piece of writing
including the song and then modify your
runs and give it a bit more useful he's
going to be listening to it so if you
want to keep going helps that simple
analysis is a lot of composition anyway
years for watching if you want to help
make these videos possible please
consider supporting on patreon you can
also join the same mailing list for
scans of all same episodes like share
comment subscribe and keep on rockin hey
guys chance - today we're gonna talk
about lose this is a bit more useful by
infinite eleven in situations who was a
pretty staff song take dark steel but if
you virgin them and if we attacking the
notes for a less part we get something
but biological you have to do those
things first if you want to learn the
are talked effectively if you have a
much straightforward tool for instance
if you want to keep going to create a
lot of different answers behind Latin
give us a Utah
is rap we get a bit of a completely
short piece of cooking and tends to be
pretty fun to approach your flats in the
spreadsheet
Jacques which will be truly library as a
dog or interact and to explain that in
the end of exercise comes out on the
rover word job or pre-plan and you can
do those we've lowest alarm sending
learning and learning your reading drill
becomes slice and I saying that you can
do be doing on pipe that the first bill
I am souvenir I think that's the fangs
he was defined by a resort for dark or
full I am shooting hope I want to work
on it law to the components of the
instruments I didn't guess whether you
can do an external into your Brando
system and night and I'm shorter earns
about the ingenuity selection
so measuring luck technical watching
start at the link below okay I never
said it was going to be good so how did
I do this and why is this relevant to
YouTube specifically I made this video
using machine learning which is a fancy
way of saying that I used statistics and
a bunch of data machine learning can be
used for a variety of applications
including image processing product
recommendations autonomous driving but
they all boil down to one key principle
that is you take a bunch of relevant
data and use that to inform a
statistical structure and that structure
will then if you give it new data which
you haven't seen before it will give you
an output specifically for this video I
built a statistical structure by a
computer code which predicted which word
was most likely to follow a given
sequence of words consider the
incomplete sentence cars without human
if you were to ask a person to predict
which word came next they would probably
say drivers or maybe inputs this is
because humans understand how language
works and imply from context that human
here is an adjective
rather than a noun cars have drivers and
so maybe the noun following the
adjective is drivers a machine has no
innate understanding of how our language
works and so can't make a prediction
based on context so how do you train it
to write
mystics and data I gather data from a
variety of amazing YouTube creators I
received written scripts for videos made
by real engineering draw a SETI Wendover
productions tear z12 tone college info
geek lessons from the screenplay and
then I added scripts for my videos into
the mix as well for good measure I then
took all the scripts and bung them into
one big file and told the computer to
look at the first 100 words given the
first 100 words and all the words that
the one hundred and first could possibly
be ie
all the words that appear at some point
in the document which one did it think
it was it took a guess in this first
instance a totally random guess and if
it was right then it changed the
statistics that governed its prediction
to make it more likely to predict that
word in the future when faced with the
same 100 input words in that order if it
was wrong then it made it less likely to
predict that word when faced with the
same inputs it then moved along by one
word considering words 2 to 101 and
tried to predict the 100 and second word
depending on if he got it right or not
it made a correction to the internal
statistics and then moved on it did this
for every 100 words segments of the file
so as it moved through all the data it
got better and better at making
predictions but by the time it reached
the end of the file it had only seen
some combinations of words once other
combinations would be more popular so to
improve the learning it then went back
to the start the file and repeated the
whole process several times after doing
that it was then capable of writing text
given a 100 word writing prompt after
taking in those 100 words it's predicted
word is added onto the end of the
writing prompt and so included in the
input data which was now 99 provided
words and one machine predicted word it
then repeats the process predicting a
word based on the input which has then
added to the end of the prompt write
more than 100 words in a row and the
machine is now working out what to write
next given what it has written before
with no more
the video essay in this video was the
product of the computer writing 500
words given my introduction and it did
some stuff surprisingly well for
instance it really nailed the end of the
video just in the middle so as far as I
can tell this was a mishmash of lots of
different outros from 12 tones videos
but they followed enough of a pattern
that the algorithm just recognized what
was going on and recreated it but then
carried on to the next script so
remember that all the scripts were on
one file one after the other so
apparently my writing prompt was
interpreted by the algorithm as being
the middle of a video rather than the
start one of the key things to note is
that obviously the script doesn't make
any sense on a gross scale but the
individual sentences sometimes I don't
want to say for the most part it makes
sense
in other words the script learned the
basic grammar and there are a couple of
more complex structures like clauses but
the sentences in context don't make any
sense and apart from a couple of
examples there isn't really any
consistent vocabulary between them I
think this is because I trained the
algorithm on lots of different YouTube
creators and they did very different
things they made videos about music
theory or about studying or about
aeroplanes and so the algorithm ended up
being an uneasy compromise between all
of their different styles and all of
their different specific vocabularies I
suspect that if you train the bots using
just one channel scripts although they'd
have to have a lot of them that you'd
end up with a better performing more
targeted but similar to those which are
already being used to write each of
videos algorithmically generated videos
have been active on this site for years
producing highly targeted videos mostly
aimed at children that's because a
there's a very large market for
children's videos and B those videos
tend to be very simple as this video is
demonstrated video essays are very
complicated to write they need to be
succinctly to be both ideally
entertaining and informative and they
have to have an overarching points there
has to be an argument this project took
me several weeks to code and run even on
high end machinery however as processor
technology evolves more sophisticated
algorithms are developed and crucially
more data becomes available
as more videos are uploaded to YouTube
and can be scraped for their content
expect to see more algorithmically
generated videos like this one and in
the future they might actually make
sense but that will be only one example
of machine learning revolutionising the
world I mentioned earlier that
autonomous vehicles are powered by
machine learning and in the future we
can expect our roads to be mostly
populated by self-driving vehicles but
it doesn't stop there if machines have
learned to drive why limit them to roads
why not let them loose on a racetrack
driverless cars could compete with one
another with teams laboring to engineer
not just the fastest car but also the
smartest AI to pilot them that would be
much more complex than what I've done
here the AI would need to manage battery
power know when and how to overtake
safely and adapt to changing weather
conditions it would be incredibly
exciting to watch and follow the
development it would be a whole new
hybrid of sport and technology except
this is already happening and it's
called Robo race this whole time you've
been looking at their self-driving cars
these are electric vehicles driven by
increasingly smart ai's developed
competitively by teams competitions have
a really long history of accelerating
technological progress and portions of
the code used by Robo race are going to
be open source so they're trying to push
forward the development of machine
learning and autonomous driving in
general they're currently in season
alpha this is the first round of
competitions between teams around the
world that developing hardware software
and the actual format of what the races
are going to be like this is an
incredibly exciting time of
experimentation and university teams
like the Technical University of Munich
are able to take part in it without
having to commit to the whole race
basically Robo race are trying to create
an environment where software engineers
can develop themselves and also the
field check out the playlist in the
description for videos all about the
technology used in the artificial
intelligence and to learn more about
season alpha they can also follow them
on Instagram and there's a mailing list
again mixed in the description over the
next couple of months I'm going to be
working with Robo race on a couple more
videos learning more about the
artificial intelligence and I'm really
excited seeing some of season alpha
self and of course I'm gonna bring you
with me thank you to roba race for
sponsoring this video and also a massive
thank you to all the channels who
volunteers their scripts to be used as
training data that we links to all of
those channels in the description as
well also linked in the description is a
video where I talk to the code of how I
made this in much more detail that's
available exclusively from a patreon so
if you'd like to watch that then please
consider supporting the channel thank
you very much for watching the video and
I'll be back next month with some more
machine learning which is going to be a
lot more driving based I'll see you then
thanks very much for watching